sí es cierto este a las cuatro y media
más o menos este bajamos en el refugio
antiaéreo porque oímos una exclusión
bastante fuerte y en estos momentos en
cambio la situación afuera en la calle
es más tranquila por lo que hemos
decidido
volver a la superficie también para
poder conectarnos y estar en contacto
con ustedes
tenéis previsto ir en es salir a la
calle salir a reportear lo que está
pasando en la capital ucraniana o por
precaución tenéis que mantenerlos dónde
estáis
de momento es todavía de noche y hay
toques de queda así que no vamos a salir
saldremos cuando se necesitan las
condiciones de seguridad cuando se
salga el sol y pues estamos cumpliendo
de hecho con las instrucciones que nos
han dado desde el gobierno hasta que
ahora no se puede salir a la calle y ha
dado el gobierno durante estas últimas
horas alguna nueva instrucción han dado
datos de lo que ha podido pasar en la
capital del país
si han confirmado un ataque sobre la
capital del país no está claro qué tipo
de ataque ha sido aún lo que hemos visto
en imágenes que se han retransmitido que
han retransmitido
desde la parte ucraniana
ha sido un vehículo
un helicóptero quizás que se ha
desplomado sobre un barrio
a los suburbios de kiev y se puede
confirmar que ha funcionado el sistema
antimisiles de la capital se han visto
algunas imágenes pero desde acá no
podemos confirmar nada no sé si ustedes
tienen más información no la verdad es
que estamos en la misma situación que
ustedes este la parte ucraniana dice
efectivamente que este que se han
derribado
y misiles procedentes de las fuerzas
rusas pero lo cierto es que en este
momento no podemos confirmar esta
información